[Music]
and their screen junkies you are
watching honest trailer commentaries the
show or we talked about the other show
to find out what we really thought about
the least controversial movie of the
year the Justice League yeah that's
Joestar that's Dan Morell if you stick
around to the end you will see a fair
amount of deleted scenes and jokes and
stuff I think we cut a bit out because
you'll get the full Snider cut but this
one is of our justice league guys
trailer guys this movie exists yeah yeah
yeah my review at the time was it's fine
whatever leave me out of it and I still
feel like this is a it reeks of what it
was which is the visions of about of two
filmmakers and about eight or nine
different executives based off of the
analytics and performances of three
other movies yeah I didn't think this
was aggressively terrible it was just a
mess in a different way that Suicide
Squad vanities Superman were messes they
were messes on their own right this was
a different kind of mess yeah I don't
think it was a mess in the sense that
you know I thought that Suicide Squad
was or Batman V Superman was in a lot of
ways where it didn't go overboard with
the plot that you it didn't get so up
its own buttons and so concerned in the
the sheer amount of plot that they could
throw on screen and the the unnecessary
you know blind alleys that the story
would take you down it just seems
shallow like it was the opposite it was
like there was nothing there you just
like kind of poke it and your finger
goes right through it like it was it was
a hollow experience it felt like it an't
like and I actually do like the animated
series and those team ups and stuff like
that it felt like a cartoon right and I
mean it given the depth of the what had
been building to and the kind of gravity
and the weight that the previous movies
had kind of yeah told you to expect this
was sort of like anyway yeah here's
cyborg newsflashes Wonder Woman and
there's a guy and they find alien and
it's done that simplicity did feel a
little bit like the writer just sat down
with his kid and the kid just pulled out
whatever toys he happened to have me
him and was like cyborgs looking at them
in the woods and then Steppenwolf
Steppenwolf is there and then Superman
is Bam's back and he punches him real
hard but the Superman fights his friends
yeah yeah it had that kind of action
figures bang against each other feeling
and I think that that is maybe an
overcorrection to the last few movies
where it's like okay fine they don't
like the critics don't like you know
this this moody you know head-scratching
a labyrinth for three hour long movie
all right this one's gonna be two hours
long it's gonna be in and out it's gonna
be they're all gonna be cracking jokes
is that what you like yeah it says this
this like kind of kids like this was
supposed to be a two-parter you cut it
down to one then the studio says and it
has to be two hours and then you have
unfortunate personal life real life
things that happens ex-knight Orson you
bring in a 2nd filmmaker on top is ex
diner who has completely an altogether
different style than Zach so you have
like done in a month
there's the antitrust laws for directors
like JJ Abrams should not be allowed to
do Star Trek and Star Wars yeah I should
take what you allowed to do leave
something for someone else that is it's
weird because I guess he's not he's not
credited as the director so a lot of
people don't think of the fact that he
directed the big team-up movies for both
DC and Marvel but he directed at least a
fair chunk of it I mean the only one you
really know which one is which is
Superman head yeah
fairly easy to tell which parts were
pickups in which parts were yeah but it
is bizarre to think about like this one
guy had his hands in both huge team-up
movies I understand the impulse because
it's like disaster strikes
and it's like who knows how to pick this
thing up I'm a document stream yeah is
there a doctor on this plate Joss
Whedon's Lee the only doctor that's
that's done this surgery before yeah was
interesting was um cuz I didn't watch it
until we had to write the honest trailer
and Batman V Superman and Suicide Squad
both I was just kind of like what's
happening like but this one I just felt
sort of sad and frustrated like oh like
as much as I'll make fun of just
people that like love those movies and
stuff like that like they still didn't
deserve this nobody deserved a DC team
up movie that was this yeah sad watching
it yeah just kind of yeah that was the
movie made as it went in one ear and out
the other which which the Justice League
shouldn't do as we discussed in our
jelly it's decent truly are the greatest
comic book heroes ever created yeah
let's watch and see what we had to say
about it
somewhere between the awful Suicide
Squad and the excellent Wonder Woman a
new DC movie we'll get it sorted down
the middle but when the best comic book
characters ever unite for a film that's
just okay you blew it again pause for a
second there was a brief shot of JK
Simmons there and I was telling these
guys earlier remember those pictures of
JK Simmons like keep lifting the most
weight ever like it yes serious like HGH
old man guns that I've like never seen
before I really wanted to make that
Detective coat look good I guess we all
just assumed that that would be for
Justice League and and Commissioner
Gordon would rip the sleeves off his
trip yes yeah and fight at that type
dark side I guess yeah himself so it's
so bizarre what he would've been a great
Darkseid is either he that got cut from
the movie that is in there matter and
there what in the Schneider cut involves
Jay case it's Commissioner Gordon
ripping his sleeves out or he's just was
doing that just cuz he's like you know
what I'll do like I'm in between movies
like I'm gonna get jacked I mean he was
never a - have you seen whiplash like
he's got he has he had two three chairs
of people like that's requires a lot of
like body comic-book movie and also you
know even if I was gonna be like the
Commissioner that's just wearing
sweaters all the time I feel like if I
was on set with Cavill and Affleck I'd
be like you know what I gotta do
something I gotta step it up alright
I'll go try your work out for a wheel or
am we also have a shot here of the the
guy like slow motion kicking over there
this plan for that was a weird opening
montage Louis from a different movie yes
of like they were really kind of trying
to set the stage of like the world is
falling apart and paralyzed by system II
because the guy they never really sold
on in the first place that's the most
afraid you've ever been in the millennia
of the time the mother box has been on
earth regardless let's carry on oranges
Zack Snyder does do great titles this is
this suit fairly obvious this is a
sniper and
yeah just great titles why Watchmen
great idea ah keep happening prophecy
John for clusters the allergy steps in
the best of a production beset by
tragedy Warner Brothers bravely forged
ahead so executives could keep their
bonuses it's an irrelevant screen he's
losing his own for discussing optimism
of Joss Whedon and the priorities of
Brett Ratner's production company
because they also skim feed up the whole
all the Amazons
yeah we've thrown a bunch of clips of
them in there cuz they're all suddenly
they're leggings kind of disappear and
the midriffs yeah and who knows in that
mess of studio notes which ones were
brett ratner's well certainly never know
now remove that from Home Videos Rat
Pack apparently really you're gonna go
they're gonna pull that card mmm
interesting but it seems it seems like a
note that would come oh yeah from Rat
Pack yeah right that was that might have
been done in jest but it does seem like
there was a lot of they they shot Wonder
Woman and the Amazons a little
differently than they did in wonder well
yeah a different perspective
there was definitely a Brett rat like I
haven't seen that Wonder Woman but
they're all lesbos right dress up sexier
thanks yeah yeah that's my Brett Ratner
gorgeous that resolves in its own
signature blend of orange wasn't a
made-up bamboo pipe dream all right
cause I'm sure that there's gonna be so
there was no it was so early in the
process that be cut was what's known as
an assembly cut as we talked about with
the flavors not in there it's it's it's
it's it's literally everything they've
shot in sequence yeah which is not like
the that's not a movie they have to
actually cut it down now maybe because
there's such a clamor for it maybe
they'll bring them back or they'll
release something and call it the Snyder
but it would require millions of dollars
and sound and most likely visual effects
work right and color timing editing
probably I'm sure stood up sure it
wasn't all edited together
no movie that was the stateroom he left
the project is done and it would require
an investment of millions of dollars
which this movie made two billion
dollars yeah sure maybe this movie
didn't know it was out grossed by I
think I'd counted it something like 13
movies worldwide it was the lowest it's
not no now maybe it finds its audience
like Blade Runner did and will get 10
different Justice % certainly it's the
final perfect that we merged it with
Watchmen for the hell of it cut like
yeah yeah Lord Harrison Ford voiceover
[Laughter]
work even if even at its most like
technical like he delivered a cut long
story short it wasn't a movie it's not a
a film that has been edited it's not a
finished version show up somewhere they
do I think because of the Batman V
Superman thing I think people assume
that there was an alternate cut of every
movie right just on a shelf so know that
that ultimate cut was like that was a
that was a done finished thing that he
presented the Warner Bros Suicide Squad
like fueled it to with like oh they took
a razor cut they gave it to the trailer
company and myrrh yeah that's there's
there's so many cuts in the Warner
vaults so many unused cuts mmm and be
interesting yeah anyways oh man I wish
the Snider cut wasn't a made up fanboy
pipe dream witness Oh Phil that looks
like it's being rendered right before
your eyes where this CGI villain steals
the CGI boxes from their CGI hiding
places uniting the CGI heroes in a big
CGI fight on a CGI battlefield until the
CGI hero merges with the CGI box while
the CGI villain gets punched in the
mouth by the hero with a mouth made out
of CGI yes ma'am that just looks wrong
meet the Justice League a bunch of sad
losers are
left alone if you stay up here brooding
I'm processing
well I wouldn't count on the tribes of
men I need friends who occasionally make
jokes now Dostoevsky there's one I think
that was annoyed Lila butter eggs that
joke I think annoyed me more than any
other really it seemed very lazy yeah
but like that seemed like something that
the flag said this flesh I know he's
divisive I thought he was good I liked
just the fact that he was different from
the rest of him who were like now that
guy's the burden of this race heavily on
my shoulders like I liked Ezra Miller
and I liked his charisma but I felt like
his character was written to be just
like wait a minute big joke like it's
like it's like some kind of Batcave I'm
like yeah okay
yes key things just like like it's the
best oh what's a word that sounds
Russian
Dostoevsky just like every joke was sold
to seventeen which I'm sure was probably
just weed no no I'm gonna not gonna fall
Ezra Miller but it's like just was like
you gotta hit these punch lines Ezra you
got to just punch the hell out of them
and it's just that every one of his
jokes for me it seemed like Oh for they
were setting up a brunch tag like
because they had like to brunch Joe
right they're gonna pay it off like the
shwarma thing where they're all getting
brunch at the end he's like what's the
deal with brunch but that's probably one
Avengers comparison too far I actually
wondered and this is one of those things
where I was like oh maybe this got lost
in the cut shuffle when they first
introduced Barry and he's going on about
brunch not understanding people I was
like are they gonna do sort of but he's
a bit like on the social spectrum or
something like that
which I was like that's I thought he was
but then it seemed like they abandoned
it but yeah because I was like oh wow
they were like really making like this
big choice with Barry Allen and then and
then he was just ya know maybe I'll
address it in flashpoint my man Wonder
Woman the
three dimensional hero turned into girl
hung up on her ex I lost someone I loved
I once knew a man who would have loved
to fly it when it seemed so hard it's
been a hundred years old
bro psyche and the brochures man who's
there booyah man who in this movie goes
by the flash Superman and mouth is so
distracting poor Henry Cavill worked out
for months for this role but all I can
look at his weird fake baby mouth they
really couldn't just shave his mustache
or grow a beard or you know delay the
movie and of course the Batman he may
not be that tough that's Marge so your
genius move is dying or that careful
with his secret identity just like a bad
first and last name he's at the end of
his career you know bud that's a shame
he was the best part of the last one can
we just roll that back roll that back to
that Aquaman thing and let's just count
the number of Billy just says just like
a bat you're out of your mind Bruce
Wayne and I just want to count keep
going keep going
careful with this secret identity you're
out of your mind Batman aka Bruce Wayne
like unless I guess they're cut off from
the fish but are they cut off from the
internet I think cut off from Twitter no
I mean nobody's tweeting as big holy
Spotify cuz at one point they're just
cranking white stripes and that weird
little pub yeah that's the thing about
the can't get into this but it's just
like the fact that the mother boxes were
hidden and no one had ever talked about
them for millennia except the carvings
on the side of this like grog house that
was a reshoot I promise I think they've
gone back and so and proof why were they
drawn in the bar do not let me just get
drunk and be like man I thought I sort
of know because this movie was so
radically they changed the villain I
mean this movie is so radically
restructured you can tell they're like
we've got to get to Steppenwolf somehow
and it's literally just like a guy blows
up and leaves in
in a box is not a thing and then Bruce
Wayne's these drawings of boxes it's all
completely coincidental it's just like
they had to completely radically
retreated the mother boxes one was
buried in a fortress in Atlantis under
water one was buried at the the temple
of the hidden Amazons I don't know
humans buried it in the dirt dump in a
hole that's like a foot deep and just
like at a little bit of Jumanji game was
buried don't tell the Atlantean yeah my
favorite thing was Bruce spends so much
at the beginning of the movie like what
is the mystery of these boxes I'm
missing something I gotta put all this
together what could be in the boxes what
are the boxes what's in the box and then
like he how did we not make up what's in
the box but then he finally after like
30 minutes checks in with Diana and he's
like you know I think it's about these
boxes and she's like yes it is here is
all the information about the boxes that
you need to know you have my phone
number wouldn't speculate he's like
let's have these boxes Alfred power
money money like what oh it's how much
money do you think is in there like
their ancient boxes of money they're
doubloons
do you think you're being invaded by
Jack Sparrow money boxes like secrets
yeah Lucy girls like slavers really
after like a couple a couple hundred
thousand bonds though like worth much
more every day that likes Luthor would
apparently be taking notes on that
weren't relevant to anything he's doing
why would the cash you know you don't
get to be a billionaire by by frittering
away your fortune you get it by
increasing find value we don't get it
money these guys aren't recruited yet
you could just run around they tell
everyone
but wait there's no bud that's a shame
he was the best part of the last one he
sewed on prepared for the arrival of
Steppenwolf
DC's scariest Horne helmeted Minor God
villain with the giant bladed weapon
since them we'll be right before this
one he's got a generic look a generic
motivation he lived only to conquer and
super generic dialogue has ever been
this much of a mother mother from the
first time I saw this movie starting
about halfway through the first time I
saw Justice League every time
Steppenwolf talked to said mother I'm
just hurried brother he's like I'm
leaving mother I just saw I just heard
Tony Hale in my mind it's just how good
he is I think I just heard mother he's
it the mother boxes right first of all
why is it why is he called the mother
that is that is a that is a comic-book
reference the mother bought they're
called mother boxes in the book that was
this thing called boom tubes and it's it
is related to Darkseid directly which
again this are the boxes his mother no
it's like they created his planet right
if he get if he gathers the three you
know Dragon Balls or whatever and yeah
and then he makes the wish and then the
earth turns into his planet yes which
was the exact plot of Man of Steel yes
yes the world engine turning in this is
the change engine this is the change
machine yes change machines is also mine
on IP transformer script
robots half disguise I have optimum
Prime it's me tremendous car I don't
remember exactly what the mother boxes
do but one one issue is it's like it's
like a sentient intelligence comics you
speak to it like mother can you do this
and mother it's like a sentient then yes
like computers well just would have made
sense if he was talking to Darkseid this
whole time because the Foxes just seemed
like the tool to accomplish what he
wants to do for his boss right who's
again there we supposed to be a setup
for Darkseid whose name drop but when
this went for two parts to one point
that it just became my my thing is like
mother boxes and boom tubes and Darkseid
and stuff like and new gods and old got
like this is all like ripped like Pete
crazy Jack Kirby so like this is stuff
that would feel at home and thor
ragnarok which is also like peek crazy
kirby thor and it just doesn't work like
in a grounded in your outages yeah yeah
i can't call this movie grimdark anymore
like the other ones but it's such a big
jump to go from like BVS to this would
be wacky and thor regular i mean it can
be done it's just that this is it's just
like literally the way that it's
introduced in this movie is the first
scene again fairly obviously a reshoot
the first scene of I'm just going Alfred
what's these oh it's those evil boxes
we've been tracking anyway we got to get
a team together the criminal who he was
busting is like who he doesn't busted
he's like I'll bet it's cuz Superman's
gone isn't it everything's been
different since Superman you wouldn't
run for his life after seeing
getting caught by Batman and then seeing
an alien demon fight him he would have
just stuck around and be like you know I
think this is happening Superman's gone
don't you Batman like 20 minutes later
he's like I wish we had some kind of
League is he cause everybody's gone just
tied up helpless on a roof
Superman's not around I use you for bait
so I'm gonna let you go okay he's still
a robber yeah Batman that man should go
to jail
there's no no human being sees how the
rest of that night plays out he's been
tied up by Batman and used as bait for a
killer alien he walks into a bars like
you're not gonna believe what happened
to me are me how is it possible the
Republic everything from the Avengers
except the good villain come on Josh
it's not stealing if you do it from
yourself from stall now if we stop
ourselves ironic I'm in Batman V
Superman check out a sequel that says
whoops never mind
pretending Batman knew Clark Kent for
more than 15 minutes
I'm teammate Clark hi again
Bruce Wayne met Clark Kent and there's
really no am big this unambiguously we
saw them meet for the first time at a
cocktail party and they almost came to
blows came to blows and then the next
time that they saw each other was when
Batman was trying to kill him and then
that and then Superman died right and
but Batman again in this movie is waxing
as if like this team needs Clark like
okay if you want to wax philosophical
about Superman is if you didn't try to
kill him until five minutes before he
died fine but there's no ground for
Bruce Wayne to be like we need Clark
like you didn't know you didn't know
Chloe you did he's doing a lot of
extrapolation from that one magical
night they spent together realize that
this was an alien who had a mom with a
name and that meant like he just made
some he's the world's greatest detective
dead so he detected from that moment
that Superman and his alter ego Clark
Kent was exactly a comic book Bruce
Wayne would indeed have said that this
team needs Clark and we need to bring
Superman back but this universe is
interests Lane had really no yeah he
wasn't even really friends there were
reasons you could have given he could
have been like I really screwed up and
we need that guy and that's also why I'm
putting together this whole league and
all this and like I realized that I'm a
crazy bat murder guy and we need or give
Amy a something to do we're like he goes
to visit her and she tells him how some
story about Clark
it's not terrible and he and that
changes his motivational well and he
like he's like hi roading wonder woman I
was just like oh and it's Steve Trevor
telling you that well stop being such a
wimp and come out into the light I'm
like I mean you didn't kill Superman but
you didn't help yeah it didn't help that
you know after that I thought that they
threw in a scene where he was like I was
trying to provoke you into being like
our leader
but yeah it's again it just smacks of
just like not really thinking through no
it smacks of like the Avengers had a
part where they're all fighting each
other it seems like they're not going to
come together yeah so yeah we need that
part there's also a sort of an
interesting like because I feel like
Wonder Woman
after her movie came out kind of
dethrown not completely dethroned but
made Batman a lot less bulletproof as
the only important DC character great
and this is a movie that clearly like
wasn't sure how to course-correct that
where it's like you guys better listen
to Batman and like as an audience member
you're like no she's pretty great like
yeah he's way stronger she seems a lot
smarter
she's a nicer person yeah remember just
getting his ass kicked and like throwing
his money around like Dan blitz Eric I'm
still cool right guys oh yeah whatever
changes that I'm teammate Clark
pretending the world didn't hate
Superman before he died of course I
think it's all because he's gone
well there's business Casilla narratives
are flash nightmare sequence never
happened
mr. esky when this movie was gonna be a
two-parter right so where the avengers
felt like the end at the beginning for
the MCU experience DC's big team up
movie that just kind of feels like the
end where they emptied out their easter
egg covered United and all their biggest
superheroes and tried everything they
could to make it look like they still
cared everyone just a little bit because
jeggings jeggings with the muscles
built-in clearly somebody didn't want to
do the Capitol just build it into my
Under Armour that's a muscle shirt it is
and we saw lifting tires in the last one
yeah the last one he was a real convict
conditioning many went through the whole
after the movie and during the movie and
yeah I think like yeah reshoots like oh
god like no I'm not eating steamed
chicken again yeah if you're not gonna
support was gangland what was his was an
after movie after bat maybe Superman
whatever yeah that one dangling Express
let's just call it ganglion Express if
you're not gonna support gangland
Express that I'm not working out sure
there's a name I don't remember GERD you
know you can't do this forever I can
barely do it now it's a shame too they
were just starting to take some real
steps toward heroism save one save one
person okay baby steps starring a wad of
tinfoil sponged around a laser pointer
my first impression is the red Dark
Knight ow the DCE you Hunger Games
champion comes out super sight I the
voice of Warner Brothers we might not
have thought this through Deadpool I
mean dead stroke
Smash Mouth ain't a spider spider car
does whatever a spider car does for a
lot of us and vehicles heads
speeder Parker and they recast Luther
hey there for a glass of good a demon oh
and seeds that weren't in the final
movie how much a channel man consumed by
water
I was conscious oh yeah as a human in a
letterman jacket the I didn't think you
were real see been thinking about real
realize it's useful cyborgs fighting a
tank and talking to a car you should
probably that's obviously from a search
by these parody n cyborg is a human
playing football the original blue color
palette in sequence
Bruce looking at holographic Superman
they'd probably Center the re-animator
killing small trees Louis is discussing
their engagement I'll take that as a yes
it's eat the mouth is really that one
yeah Warner Brothers presents Joss
Whedon Zack Snyder's justice listen
uation of RVs of loved one yes so why
does everyone this we have supers
banging fear I can smell us
the demons must have got the scent of
the waterboxx who sent his own you could
smell a story organize this low did I
not before yeah weird right yeah
my favorite Superman joke that didn't
make it in was that scene where he comes
back to life and then cyborg I can't
Doctor Strange himself into attacking
him it's my arm I can't control it
really that's the best motivation I
guess I'm sure notice but my very tumor
drug didn't make it in was like not only
did he in the course of fighting was odd
destroy metropolis and of course in that
scene he was destroying the memorial to
the people who died in the destruction
of metropolis that he's the statue is
just like he he will not let these poor
people know no the rest would like poor
denizens of Metropolis
well let's see what else was left on the
cutting room floor in the starring black
mirror cyborg existence is futile the
shape of hotter Vinnie chase it in
Lucille awful Downton crabby used to be
mild Stefan wetter the better ah mr.
Miller it comes in the winter when the
people are hungry it brings fish Aquaman
brings them fish you murderer so uh how
exactly is Clark Kent gonna explain how
he's back at work to the Daily Planet
I mean he was buried publicly in a grave
with the name Clark Kent on it
and I get that say Martha why not write
again I mean why did Batman just try
live it work like you did that was the
thing that snapped
Batman out of any Sweden didn't throw
that in it's like a yeah how much do you
wanna bet that it's some draft of the
script when that moment happened that
someone tossed around the idea that
Batman would say to Superman Martha yeah
or like poetry it rhymes yeah yeah it
would be good and you could have had
like the flash take the air everybody
have the same names like oh well what
could have been it's not a cut board and
Miller's cut of Snyder's cut the
original non rogue one scenes yeah yeah
well we give it a hard time it wasn't a
terrible movie it's just you gotta have
high expectations when you're doing a
massive superhero franchise team-up
there's other things like it out there
to compare to that it just doesn't hit
home in fine I'll I'll watch it if it's
on cable but it's like it's not like a
thing I need to go out and seek out
again No whatever yeah it's fine leave
us out of it but please leave us in your
life when you come back next week where
we will be discussing some prestigious
very prestigious company yes oh yeah
right
yeah is that next week wait I don't know
it no is it not yeah okay yeah it's
scheduled they have no idea what
I think it'll be a golden opportunity to
see some some of your favorites I think
so if it is indeed what I think it is
which I think it is but I'm not sure
yeah
I am also pretty sure that I know what
it is and hopefully when we present what
it is we don't say the wrong thing yeah
we might actually actually accidentally
be presenting the wrong film here which
really a bear said very yeah I hope it
oh absolutely
hopefully it's not someone else's honest
trailer yeah
all right kids see you next week
[Music]
you